So, you might be wondering why anyone
would ever choose pulling over pushing
because there's no obvious
advantage to pulling.
So does that mean that
you missed something?
No, you didn't.
Properly configured pushing will
always be less expensive for
the device on which your app is running.
It will lead to fewer syncs, which will
lead to fewer uses of the cellular
radio, which will lead
to longer battery life.
It also makes things
easier on your server,
who won't have to deal with
nagging devices all day everyday.
Note, however,
that I said properly configured.
The cost here is extra engineering
effort to set up the pushing server.
And it isn't always a simple process.
So that's why we introduced
Google Cloud Messaging,
to make it easy to communicate
with your applications.